our legacy isn't how many comments we
have enough make it go it's who were
lucky enough to have in our lives and
what we can need them okay remind me
again we can't put you on a gifted
school because it's better for my cycle
so people don't move for me to interact
with the peer group at enormous go
environment oh yeah
[Music]
Susan I guess I could just set you up a
direct deposit if that's easier
I don't know what does carry you to ask
your 11 year old did our financial
statement come in the mail today yeah I
forgot to give it to you I don't know
how you do it all by yourself
come on I have Henry find me another
male of the species we've more grown up
than him I'd like to this story about me
my brother my mom and I go who the big
store Henry and Peter they're lucky to
have you and your father is lucky to
have you too stepfather
okay I'm good mom no you sodium is very
important Christine is in trouble when
someone hurts someone else we have to
make it better there's only one way to
stop it
I'd hope to do it all myself but that's
not an option has to be another way to
help Christina mr. Stillman is the
police commissioner I'm not going to
subject him to public scrutiny without
conclusive evidence my watch
okay what do they cost mum everything
you need is right here I'll be with you
the whole time
I know it is done Henry documented
dollars you think they gonna believe it
can't be left on darkness no matter what
so I'm not panicking
we have to make it better
[Music]
you